oh now easily as you guys know something
very important came out maybe not
important to all of you but according to
me the Apple watch came out yes and I
have been giving a lot of heat because I
kind of put out a statement that I want
the watch now a lot of you out there are
saying stuff like well Sampson Lurie
came out with the watch and George was
first so why are you so hot about the
Apple watch for one good reason is
because that keynote speech for some
reason the way Apple presents all this
[ __ ] it fools me every time they always
use that dude with that British accent
is he even really the CEO I think they
just grab a random do from the street is
it look say say saved in that British
thing I don't even know if you guys
really realizes or not but anything with
the British accent sounds dope it's true
it's a fact look it up it's on Saul
[ __ ] pedia Wikipedia cuz you guys damn
well know that every single Asian dudes
secret desire is to get what the Asian
girl with the British accent cuz that's
hot it doesn't matter what she says you
tell me the phone go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
myself let me take some mouse
what's your name let me get your number
what people are going to this whole
Android versus iPhone thing why do you
care about what somebody else has or a
[ __ ] phone
who cares yeah go get the [ __ ] answer
you like iPhone go get the iPhone at the
end of the day you know what the phone's
purpose is to [ __ ] call a
[ __ ] do you guys have to
understand something to me that's the
dopey [ __ ] on earth when we were younger
we I used to watch Star Trek I would
start ranking and they you know they
found my people talk to people that did
was a baby what's your name
let me tell you later both of you wanna
get some peace don't care man actually
I'm not even sure if the Apple phone can
receive calls yet but I'm pretty sure it
does or will and if it doesn't I still
want it I don't want it but Apple you
know what your one problem isn't the way
you market this product you always
market it to people with money sometimes
you need to market it to Brooke because
people because we want to do here's an
apple you can bet you later if you want
to market your [ __ ] to get all folks you
got to act like you're not supposed to
talk about it like it's a drug deal you
know every time a broke-ass ghetto
person got to tell you something they
gotta act like someone
right behind the back baby y'all you're
about the whole circuit sometimes I just
throw out words that even I don't know
what the [ __ ] it does and watch these
[ __ ] be like and another thing
on top of that just because I want the
watch doesn't mean I'm gonna buy it
doesn't mean not for [ __ ] afford it
that shit's expensive as hell we had a
dog for the base price too much of
goddamn mine I find and groceries fight
whatever you say about the a product in
whether your Android or Apple once again
you've got to admit that [ __ ] is pretty
[ __ ] tight I mean it does that whole
thing where a monitor is your heartbeat
I don't I don't know why it would I
don't do much activity in the first
place
they probably won't tell too much they
probably think I'm dead both videos for
Samsung and iPhone and not one of y'all
[ __ ] one spots me I'm gonna
bring this up to you right now Samsung
you Korean I'm critical idiot never
looks Corey I saw stay together like a
like a glue like a grocer it's a cookie
and I miss em milk cream but if you
don't want to sponsor me [ __ ] you Apple
what's up I live in America number one
its most Asian thing I've ever done in
my life
whoever give me my money can't be
strange why don't you guys go ahead and
leave in the comments what you think
about the Apple iWatch
I'm curious cuz I want to know cuz I
just might buy it after I robbed a
couple banks and I still a couple
lollipops from a couple babies that's
all it ain't easy being broke when you
look at a Subway sandwich like it's a
fancy meal
oh [ __ ] that wasn't even I thought it
was a spider but it was like sweat
dripping down my legs as hot as a
[ __ ] up in here